hey dude the 90s called the podcast is
officially out is this like a hey dude
re-watch are you gonna tackle 90s Trends
how do you envision this all rolling out
oh no we're we're our first episode is a
reunion of the hey dude cast but we
wanted to start with you know our our
you know core base and our close circle
of friends Christine has arranged an
amazing uh reunion of The Brady Bunch
Movie cast and I arranged a reunion of
the movie white squall uh and that whole
cast but then we want to expand it into
athletes musicians anyone who made a
mark in the decade of the 90s
um we're interested in speaking to right
now we have all of the siblings we have
the Brady kids and we have um Henriette
who played Alice we're working on
schedules for Jesse who played Bobby and
um Gary Cole there have been little mini
sort of
um mini reunions and interviews and over
the years but not all of us have been
together sort of in this scale of a
group so we're gonna we're so excited it
was the last decade before smartphones
and social media and there's something
kind of special about that when we look
back on on the work that was done in the
90s that so many people enjoyed it at
the same time
on hey dude the ones that you get
recognized for most often often when
you're out in the world
for me I think it's more of a of Marcia
Brady and that's what I usually expect
and by the way there are people who
think that I'm like the original but
they'll think I'm Marie McCormick
Marcia Brady before you did the Brady
before I did Marcia Brady exactly
um but I'm always surprised when I think
someone's going to say oh I love The
Brady Bunch and then it's it's hey dude
and so and it's it's I I'm complimented
they still recognize me
David are you getting Ted fans out in
the street all of us
um you know at least a weekly or monthly
basis have
people come over to us and tell us how
uh what a what a meaningful part of
their childhood the show was the hey
dude fan base
is so passionate and it's another level
of excitement for sure one of the things
that I think is is so fascinating that
I'm I'm learning as I'm listening you
know to the podcast is that you know you
guys were kids thrust into the spotlight
kind of before this whole like Disney
Channel explosion happened you were just
a bunch of kids living in Tucson Arizona
explain to me how that all worked was
there really no supervision at this
hotel that you guys were all hanging out
at we really had a lot of freedom I
don't I don't know if uh stuff that went
down then would would fly now but um
like in what way like just you guys
being 16 or 17 years old living in a
hotel on your own
with no parents there were no I I mean I
don't think legally that would even be
allowed these days they did assign legal
Guardians to us and they were part of
the production company and you know we
because the crew everyone was in their
you know 20s 30s we had those authority
figures I felt like but we weren't
accountable really to them however David
we were good kids like when I look back
on it we probably could have taken more
advantage of the freedoms that we had
but we were kind of like good kids like
rule followers even yeah we were going
to the mall and spending our per diem
and uh you know just doing yeah we we
could have been a lot worse but I I will
say being on a cable show in 1990 is not
what it is right now you know we weren't
under a spotlight we didn't even know
people were watching the first year we
were making the show it took a while for
us to even realize uh the impact that
the show was having
I mean I think you blew all of our
brains when after 30 years the two
review revealed that there was a little
romance going on behind the scenes and
you know 30 years is a really long time
to keep something so close to the chest
why why keep it a secret why was it
something you guys didn't want the world
to know about
well to be honest we didn't really think
anyone cared right it was like head and
Melody in real life we care yeah now we
know that we know that now Jill your
wife David was the first person to say
like you guys should definitely talk
about that and I was like let's let's
like
what what better for the fans than to
hear like the real good behind the
scenes drama
comedy and drama was this your first
like real love and experience with kind
of those seminal life moments
for me it was for sure Christine was
absolutely My First Love and it was it
was intense because we were living
together in you know there wasn't that
space to breathe you know it was uh and
we were working on every day together so
when we would fight you know apparently
the whole cast and crew knew and they
could hear us going on our little roller
coaster and yeah it was it was but as
much turbulence as there was and
Christine had a boyfriend from high
school so I wasn't her first love but
all I remember are so many great times
and laughs and Christine's like family
to me like we know each other and you
know when you put some time between it
you really just remember the good stuff
I think oh for sure and Christine I want
to ask you because I I always I always
think about actors who are in these
particular positions where you're dating
somebody that you're working with and
then sometimes life happens and you
still gotta show up to work on Monday
how did you navigate all of that well I
it's always
um the universe works yes the universe
works in those ways where there would be
episodes where David and I or Melody and
Ted wouldn't even like be working
together for a lot of them but I
remember specifically the episode that
we shot right after the the split and it
was we were handcuffed together in every
scene and it's just sort of like really
universe
that is the universe congratulations to
both of you you found so much success
after the show that kind of put you on
the map David I want to talk to you
first you know you have been on pretty
much every quintessential 90s sitcom
from Blossom to Sabrina to clueless to
my personal favorite Two of a Kind
working with the Olsen twins who we
don't get to see a lot of these days
were you surprised when when they said
goodbye to acting I definitely want to
get them on the show if we can
um and I I have to say I I probably did
the only thing in their entire life that
got canceled and wasn't a huge smashing
success we did one season but um yeah
yeah it was a great show and they were
they're such professionals no I wasn't
surprised because they they had this
entrepreneurial Spirit about them
um but yeah all those shows Blossom and
Sabrina specifically were like you know
families to me for sure and Christine
you touched on it already but you know
you are you are truly iconic as as
Marcia Brady dinner's ready
it opened so many doors it really sort
of you know in the world of comedy in
particular
um you know I I I I just had all these
wonderful opportunities I think the
tricky thing when you're when you're
portraying a character there were a lot
of people that really just thought I was
like a great Marcia Brady in person
and I think on the flip side of that it
also was sort of like you know Ben
Stiller being one of them when when I
went to audition for him for a project
that I did end up getting but it
originally he was like no no that's like
she's too Marcia Brady so I you know you
you're damned if you do damned if you
don't sometimes right yeah 100 I will I
wouldn't trade it for the world no and I
don't know if you're aware of this but
the sure-jan GIF is one of the most
popular on social media sure Jan do
people ever send it to you yes people
will send it to me and then I'll I'll
see it if I'm rolling through I feel
like during the election it came like
there's literally like politicians who
post it and like who knew who knew um
but you know Jennifer and I will talk
about that when we um when we all come
together for our reunion episode I love
that you mentioned Ben Stiller I gotta
congratulate you you're coming up on 23
years of marriage when you think about
when you think about that and how
successful you guys have been together
approaching a huge number like 23 what
comes to mind
you know I I feel like relationships are
grow you grow with them like we I mean I
I feel like for us I I for me
I was in my late 20s when we met and now
I'm 51 so I mean you grow and you ebb
and flow and I really think it's just
about constant communication
um and you ride the waves of the up and
downs and and you know figure it out and
I'm really lucky and um yeah 23 years
goes by fast I love the smile on your
face and I just have to tell you as a
fan of you it really touched me and so
many people to see that you know the
pandemic was a challenging time for a
lot of us but it was really beautiful
seeing how that brought you together is
is that the result of spending 24 7
together I think so I think you know
it's you know again long-term marriages
um we it was good for us for a period of
time to have some space and then the
pandemic brought us together and that
was what was right for us and that was
ultimately what was meant to be and so
I'm very grateful for that you know
there are some silver linings for sure
but you both have kids who are kind of
following in the family business and
exploring the Arts David your daughter
is a certified Tick Tock star with over
a million followers what did you make of
it you know what was very cool to me is
that Chelsea was at Jingle Ball at
Madison Square Garden because she was
doing the shows with Jax and I heart had
Christine and I doing our first bit of
press on the same red carpet as Chelsea
and you talk about yeah full circle
moment and just watching her do her
thing which is a different medium that I
just don't get but I I love her and I
love Jax and I love what they're doing
and Christine congratulations your
daughter is just crushing it at
Juilliard what do you make of her
choosing to go down this path that her
grandparents and her parents very
famously have you know carved out I am
so proud of her I mean it was really
like her love and passion from a very
young age and I think she was exposed to
a lot of it through us but it really
came from inside her and
um you know she's worked really hard and
and you know I I believe that there is a
sort of genetic piece because for Ben's
parents for us and then for for her
right now
um you know she loves it and is pursuing
her dream and um you know studying at a
great school so I'm so proud of her is
there a project that is your kids
favorite and is there one that you're
like I'd be cool if you never saw that
one
I wrote and directed uh my first film
that was sort of semi-autobiographical
um and my kids were really fascinated by
that that's their favorite and we I
tried to show them hey dude and
I don't know if the look of the show or
what it was it was maybe timed out but
um
yeah I don't know Christine how about
you my son's favorite one of his
favorites is dodgeball like he is
obsessed with dodgeball so I like I I my
street cred really got up to that movie
he thinks I'm kind of cool that I'm in
that movie are you
reading the dictionary
he caught me I like to break a mental
sweat too grab a chair a lot of the
projects like you know now that my kids
are older they're finding them on their
own but Ben and I were not the parents I
mean we we all tried hey dude with our
kids just because and it didn't really
take it's just not as as slick and as
quick and as edgy as the shows they're
used to if they find the the shows or
the movies then great but um I'm sort of
like do your thing well I have to tell
you I'm personally manifesting you and
your daughter doing some sort of a
situation on Severance that is my goal
for 2020. oh yeah is that in the works
that is not in the works that is I I
like I like where you're going with it
I'm always open I I I'm an open-minded
gal and it comes to uh working with my
family if that's for sure
[Music]